after all of the time that you know the
years that have passed i i never
received a phone call about about him i
never talked to another head coach about
it i never talked to anybody about it
until today
i got a phone call today i'm gonna tell
you who was but i got a phone call today
in in in asking inquiring about the
situation so i know you know
somebody's interested you know and and
uh um and that and he you know so we'll
see what happens with that i i thought
that was the irony of that was crazy
because i know i'm coming on your press
conference you guys are gonna ask me a
million questions about this today i got
a phone call today for the first time
seahawks peach uh peach or coach pete
carroll i'll get it right one of these
times seahawks coach pete carroll
yesterday talking to reporters about a
team calling because remember the
seahawks the only team that brought
colin kaepernick in for a visit three
years ago somebody apparently doing a
little homework doing a little due
diligence to see if they should continue
to consider and ultimately pursue colin
kaepernick so today's draft teams that
should give colin kaepernick a shot
shereen gets a shot at the trivia
question all right shireen are you ready
maybe
all right colin kaepernick has played
one game in his career against the
dallas cowboys one game it was week one
of the 2014 season in that game he threw
two touchdown passes to the same person
who caught the touchdown passes
oh the red light is on i should know
that right and the red light's on and
cindy brady
i don't know
who was it vernon davis vernon davis
tight enough that's a great one that's a
good
that's a good one matt
21 to three was the lead by who in that
game matt casey the cowboys were up or
the 49ers were up the nine is wrong
49ers they won 28-17
so uh 2014 season just a couple of years
before his career with the team ended
alright i get the first pick and i'm
gonna i'm gonna reiterate the team that
i mentioned earlier this week in the
aftermath of al sharpton who delivered
the eulogy at the george floyd funeral
in houston saying that the nfl needs to
repair colin kaepernick
houston i looked at the texans depth
chart i looked at desean watson as the
starter i looked at the backup aj
mccarron i remember one of the false
narratives we heard a couple of years
ago was well colin kaepernick really
doesn't fit as a backup because he
doesn't match the skill set of the
starter it doesn't make sense to have
him as the backup
right there are plenty of backups who
don't match the skill set of the starter
including in houston where aj mccarron
is the backup to desean watson colin
kaepernick would be a much better backup
to desean watson colin kaepernick could
come in and run the same offense to sean
watson run so for me
choice number one given the the
combination that george floyd born and
raised in houston
uh the texans could use him and uh given
that there was kind of a rocky history a
few years ago with some of the things
that happened during the original anthem
controversy i think the texans would
make a ton of sense from a football
standpoint and from just the broader
standpoint of doing the right thing at
the right time so give me the texans
first shireen
mike they were not might would have been
my number one pick too for for all the
same reasons and cal mcnair and bill
o'brien have been super supportive
of the texans this time around and and i
think you're going to hear some
different comments from bill o'brien
coming up this week uh weekend from my
good friend john mclean from the houston
chronicle has talked to both of those
guys and i've talked to him i talked to
him last night and and i think you're
going to see a really good story
on the way they've supported their
players in this thing and the way
they'll support them going forward and
it is going to be different in houston
and so they would have been my number
one
pick i'm going to make with the second
overall selection i'm going to pick the
vikings and and that's for some of the
same reasons
george floyd obviously died in
minneapolis i think it would help with
this healing process there
if you bring him in
they've committed to kirk cousins so
he's not going to be looking over his
shoulder
at colin kaepernick i think he's pretty
secure that he's the starter there so i
think that helps and again when you look
at their depth chart you see sean
mannion some guy named nate stanley some
guy named jake browning i mean
he would be an upgrade
on the backups they have there so
minnesota would be my first pick second
overall choice
yeah i like that one very much and again
we mentioned earlier in the show the
gary kubiak connection offensive
coordinator now was the head coach in
denver when john elway the gm of the
broncos considered trading for colin
kaepernick before what was his final
season with the 49ers i'm gonna go with
the baltimore ravens here and i know
they have rg3 a backup who ostensibly
matches the skill set of starter lamar
jackson i don't know frankly that rg3
is as good as colin kaepernick at his
best if you can get colin kaepernick to
his best but the ravens were one of the
teams that was interested in kaepernick
in 2017. they reportedly were close to
bringing in for a workout there was
something his girlfriend posted on
social media that caused them to pull
the plug ray lewis eventually talked
publicly about that look now is the time
to set aside that kind of stuff and not
worry about that and worry about doing
what's right and i think it would be
right for the ravens to have a better
alternative than rg3 is the backup to
lamar jackson
when you have a quarterback who runs the
ball from time to time whether it's
designed or whether it's a result of
scrambling away from a pass rush you're
running the risk that he's going to get
injured now with lavar jackson you got
to catch him before you can actually hit
him and potentially result in an injury
but i think kaepernick would be a better
backup option to rg3 for the baltimore
ravens and if we talk about this urgency
and it really struck me the way al
sharpton put it that colin kaepernick
needs to be repaired part of the repair
process is to go back and make things
that went wrong right and one of the
things that went wrong was that decision
by the ravens to pull the plug on the
workout because of something that his
girlfriend posted on social media those
aren't the considerations that a
football team should have should be
whether or not the guy is worthy of a
job whether or not the guy is worthy of
a spot whether or not the guy is good
enough to make the team better and and i
think the ravens in that regard would
make plenty of sense sharing
well the next pick is pretty tough
because there's so many choices i just
think there's a lot of good options out
there
for colin kaepernick but i think with my
next choice i think i'm going to go with
the kansas city chiefs
because andy reid has never shown an
aversion to giving a guy a second chance
he's done it with multiple players
multiple times
and this would be a good fit
for colin kaepernick to go in and and to
have time to to learn the offense to get
back integrated in a program because
he's been out of football so long
patrick mahomes obviously is the starter
he's not going to be replaced chad
hennes the backup and let's not forget
that rosters are going to be expanded
and you're going to probably carry three
quarterbacks this year because of the
threat of the coronavirus he would fit
perfectly there with patrick mahomes
same type of offense chad henny and then
you keep colin kaepernick and you let
him
get integrated back into the nfl slowly
it just it makes a ton of sense uh in
kansas city to go with andy reid
you mentioned second chances and it was
andy reid who gave mike vick his second
chance and again vic was out for two
years because of something he did
kaepernick out for three years for
reasons unrelated to any type of
wrongdoing he did something the nfl
didn't like and he suffered the
consequence and he's still suffering the
consequence to this day so look we
talked earlier about things patrick
mahomes is doing the actions he's taken
we don't know what's going on behind the
scenes there for all we know patrick
mahomes and tyron matthew are constantly
peppering andy reed with text messages
to bring in colin kaepernick we need to
be the leaders here we need to be the
ones who do this somebody's going to do
this he makes the team better i mean
look at what happened last year when
patrick mahomes got injured if matt
moore doesn't come in and scrape
together a couple of wins
they don't have a buy going into the
playoffs if they don't have a buy
how do they make it to the super bowl
how do they win the super bowl without
the benefit of great backup quarterback
play so i for for football reasons and
for these broader reasons of how we are
going to behave in this moment i think
the chiefs make a ton of sense right i'm
torn between two teams here with with my
pick um and i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go with the patriots i'm gonna
go with the patriots
it was a patriot it was down to the
patriots and another team i'm going with
the patriots remember 2012 that sunday
night
when colin kaepernick went
to new england for the first time
the the 49ers built a huge lead he ran
through and around the patriots defense
and then when the patriots tied it up
what did he do coolly and calmly
engineered a drive that won the game and
we've seen the bill belichick defense
struggle with mobile quarterbacks from
time to time i think because it's so
based on scheme you know when the scheme
that is there for the play that's called
breaks down because the play that was
called morphs into backyard football
the players
just can't keep up with a guy who is
physically superior and can run around
them and through them and wouldn't that
be a great weapon for the new england
patriots offense i know that that
they're they're they're committed to
next man up and what does jared stidham
have but hey
jared stidham and colin kaepernick all
due respect to brian hoyer is a better
combination in my mind than jared
stidham and brian hoyer
yeah and they were my pick mike they
were going to be my third pick i think
it's a great choice they do need a
starting quarterback um but even if they
don't
who's your third guy again i think
you're going to have to carry three
quarterbacks and i think he would be a
perfect fit there as your third
quarterback and bill belichick he's
never cared what's been said outside the
organization why would he care what's
said if colin kaepernick comes in if
they sign him so i think that's a great
spot for colin kaepernick and they would
have been my third pick and kind of like
you now i'm kind of torn i have three
teams on my list i have the cardinals i
have washington and i have the seahawks
and i think i'm going to go with
washington simply because we talked
about the mascot earlier in the show
it's a broader picture and i think
from from that standpoint i think it
would be a great signing for washington
go out and sign colin kaepernick i know
they traded for kyle allen and and i
know ron rivera likes kyle allen the the
the aggie the i guess we can call him we
don't ever say x aggie but i guess we
can call him x aggie says he didn't
finish his career there but colin
kaepernick's an upgrade on him but again
even if if kyle allen your backup colin
kaepernick can be your third guy there
he's a lot like dwayne haskins he can
help dwayne haskins which dwayne
hassan's is going to need a veteran
presence kyle allen isn't that guy to
help dwayne haskins he hasn't been in
the league long enough he can help him
learn the offense because it's the same
offense but i think colin kaepernick
could do good things for dwayne haskins
he could do good things for that
organization as well
steelers were the team that i was
struggling with when it was between the
steelers and the patriots because mason
rudolph duck hodges all due respect not
colin kaepernick all right we got to
take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports